alright what's going on everybody
welcome to another video series this is
going to be a series about all this
right here so after playing with the
Raspberry Pi car for a while I started
to get the bite for something else ok so
I've always kind of been pretty
impressed with quad copters especially
the autonomous quad copters and so my
idea was to build a quad copter and put
something like a Raspberry Pi on there
and control the quadcopter by the
Raspberry Pi and eventually move into
complete autonomy so with the car one of
the things that I've learned with the
Raspberry Pi is it's a great little
device but it's not very powerful and so
with the quadcopter while the Raspberry
Pi could indeed control all four of
these motors probably would need at
least two raspberry PI's to make this
fully functional because of the
processing speed of a Raspberry Pi as
well as you know they're just basically
the time it takes for it to think send
messages and just be powered enough to
do that so right now what's on here is
actually this cake a board and that's
all that's required to fly this so the
kid I bought is this 5 it's like X 5 25
or 525 bags or something like that and I
got it from Amazon but you can buy this
kit from like all sorts of places I got
on Amazon SATA Amazon giftcard so that's
when I got it there so the kid was
actually pretty nice as far as supplies
are concerned putting together the kit
was a massive pain in the butt because
you know just visually putting it
together there's no problem
setting up the cake a board and
calibrating the es es to work with your
controller is just I don't even know I
don't know why it's so difficult but
there's no like clear instructions
anywhere and depending on what you've
got because the ESD s are different
right so there's a brand of esc and hese
might be calibrated differently then
you've got the kk board that's on here
now everyone says if you look it up go
keh keh multicopter calm well good luck
with that that website doesn't exist
anymore
so giving this all set up is kind of
tricky and eventually might not even be
there might not even be a point using
this because on my end goal is to
actually use a rack something like a
Raspberry Pi now that brings me to my
next thing is not too long ago I was
searching for Raspberry Pi supercomputer
just to see where I ranked in searches
and I came across this article about
this taker of k1 and how it was
competing with the Raspberry Pi I don't
really think that's the case but I had
never heard of the Tegra k1 so I started
reading into that and then I found that
there was a contest at the time you
could enter a proposal about what you
would do with your Tager k1 and they
would send you one and so I entered that
and they are sending me one right now so
that is probably what will find its way
right on here is a Tegra k1 instead of a
Raspberry Pi it's a lot more powerful
and actually it's not just a Tegra k1
it's a it's the Jetson taker k1 dev kit
so it's not just that process or it's
basically like a raspberry super strong
Raspberry Pi so I'm really excited to
play with that I think that'll handle
heat this really well but this also from
what I've seen of the motors now you'll
probably I guess you can't really tell I
do oh right yeah you can see this one
got propellers on some of these now a
lot of people might be like oh you
shouldn't have propellers on there or
developing or whatever and you shouldn't
what I ended up doing and check like a
lot of the stuff with the propellers was
you just cut out like a circle on a
piece of paper you put the arrow that
you expect forward to be for the motor
and you pluck that on to the motor shaft
here and that's what you used to develop
now this is my main complaint with the
kit is not only were the instructions
horrendous the parts were some parts you
got lots of extras some parts she you
got the exact number so this was kind of
problematic because and then some of
your missing parts so you had to kind of
improvise with the extra parts that you
got but it got together for the most
part except for right here I don't have
a propeller on here because as
I was done developing I started put him
up repellers on I'm all excited I'm
gonna fly this thing
and it turns out these little one of
these propeller mounts the way they work
is they're basically a clamp that clamps
on to the propeller at the same time it
clamps on the motor shaft and it screws
on right here and so as it pushes these
two pieces together this is also a clamp
down here I don't know what the official
term is but as this piece slides down on
it closes tighter so as you screw this
on this closes tighter and this closes
tighter and that's what holds on the
propeller one of them was it wasn't that
it wasn't stripped it was that it was
completely stripped and so it would not
screw so I had to order another one
hopefully I got the right one but I'm
still waiting on that so a massive
bummer very annoying to get to that
point after building this entire thing
finally calibrating this and getting it
to work this is another thing you might
not need a cake a board you also might
not even need a controller but I did
event I did actually buy one I figure it
might actually be a good thing to have a
controller that way you have some sort
of failsafe that you could fall back on
and have a controller carry precedence
over any input that is coming from the
board anyway so that's that obviously
these will eventually be better secured
and all that as well but didn't quite
get that far so anyway that's the kit
that I got pretty happy with it was
really cheap like 130 bucks for
basically everything you see here the
only thing extra that you would have to
buy is a battery doesn't come with the
batteries they assume most people have
their own battery as they build up so
there's no battery that came with it I'm
trying to think of what else didn't come
with it you also you had to do all your
soldering yourself so you would need
like a soldering gun and stuff and it's
also some sort of charger for the
battery this is a balancing charger also
horrible instructions that came with it
luckily some somebody made a video for
it on YouTube how to use this and super
easy if you just follow the YouTube
video
so that's that this is actually my box
that is my dev box what I've done here
is before I suggest that anybody take
off a quadcopter that they just built it
would be wise that you have some sort of
control and so mine I guess you can't
really see but I made you know kind of
like a what do you call these things I
forget what the official term a
childhood term of that is but anyway so
I use that so you hold it in place
there's also a cord over here attached
to a zip tie that's attached to the the
actual frame itself as well for a kind
of a fallback just in case those strips
fail so this way it's max height is this
high right and I would be able to see it
turn and all that if it make sure
everything works before we go ahead and
set this off because it is important to
understand that these propellers will
just slice your skin right open so it's
not something you want flying around
before you feel like you're in at least
a little bit of control so anyway so
that's that again I'm pretty happy with
it I think for the money it's a good kit
to have I'm really excited to play with
them I'm down about this but still for
the money it's pretty darn good so the
controller - that was another thing that
because you have to you don't have to
bind the controller to your receiver
because the receiver comes with the
controller and eventually if you have
like a Raspberry Pi on board or Arduino
or what I'm gonna probably put on yours
at Aker k1 dev kit whatever you have on
there that might be your controlling but
I expect that most people would want to
have a controller as a fail-safe so
anyway getting the controller calibrated
to the es sees that calibrate to the
mill I don't know it was just really
confusing for a while and the pictures
that come in the instructions that come
have been like photocopied like nine
times or something so it was kind of
confusing but nothing that a bunch of
Google searches and trial and error
couldn't solve so if anyone happens to
get this and has any questions I can
probably help you out as far as
especially when it comes to arming the
board that took me forever to figure out
how do I get this thing to actually arm
so it was kind of a pain in the Dukas
but yeah
so anyway that's what you guys have to
look forward to
as I developed with this thing maybe
eventually I'll put out a tutorial on
all of it not really the most new
friendly topic especially moving forward
with an autonomous quadcopter the RC car
was really easy to these tutorials on so
it wasn't too in-depth whereas this will
be very in-depth because you've got
gyros and all this kind of stuff and it
needs to react faster than our car did
so there's a lot more important because
this thing my only complaint is this
thing when it crashes is going to just
die probably so it's gonna need a lot of
repairs if this ever goes down so anyway
a lot of a lot of coding work will have
to go into this but anyway so that's it
for now if you guys have any questions
or comments feel free to leave them
below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time